netflix's new fantasy series based off a  dc comic  sweet tooth really mostly lives up to  the hype here  it is filled with great performances  especially by the lead christian country  who plays our main character of gus  what makes it stand out to other fantasy  shows is that it's a more hopeful  fantasy it's not trying to be game of  thrones or everything's trying to be  dark fantasy now  this is really feel good and it's done  really well  it does hit a little bit of a messy  patch in the middle but  you're going to get your payoffs and the  beginning is fantastic you're going to  like every single character  it's definitely worth the watch on  netflix i'm giving this one an 8.7